in tonight's special reports spotlight
on the midterms we turn our attention to
the governor's races currently
republicans control 27 governorships to
democrats 23.
36 states will hold elections for
governor next year 20 are led by
republicans democrats are defending 16.
but only seven are considered toss-ups
right now in what's become battleground
georgia democrat stacey abrams announced
she is running she wants a rematch with
our guest governor brian kemp she lost
in 2018 in a nail-biter election but
before she gets that chance kemp will
have to fend off a primary challenge
former senator david perdue announced
this week he wants kemp's job governor
kam thanks for joining us good to be on
will you brett so are you surprised that
you're getting primaried in this race
well listen i've been preparing for
three years for a really tough
re-election cycle this is a battle for
the soul of our state nothing surprises
me in politics these days
but listen i've been in the fight you
know i've been in the fight to keep our
economy open to keep our kids in the
classroom to make sure our church is
never closed in georgia i've been in the
fight standing with our law enforcement
officials and our men and women that are
on the ground every day and the other
side wants to do exactly the opposite of
that that is what the fight for the soul
of this state is going to be about them
wanting to close down not having our
kids in school not wanting our churches
to be open you know not having a great
economy defunding the police and if
anybody else is getting in that fight
you'd have to ask them why yeah david
perdue however in his announcement uh
for running in this primary
slammed you take a listen
unfortunately today we are divided and
brian kemp and brad raffensburg are to
blame
look i like brian
this isn't personal
it's simple he has failed all of us and
cannot win in november what's your
response to that governor well the guy i
guess can't get over the fact that he
lost to a 33 year old nobody uh and is
trying to find blame on anybody and he's
not being truthful with people and while
david perdue was at home playing golf
for nine months we passed the election
integrity act you know his campaign and
his lawyers they could have been in the
courtroom if he saw these things going
on they could have challenged the
election they could have asked for a
recount he's just out to blame other
people i'm not doing that i'm going to
be running on my record which is a dang
good one and i'm looking forward to
talking to the voters about that whether
it's against him anybody else in the
primary and certainly stacey abrams do
you feel though governor that you're
kind of running against former president
trump i mean he's weighed in already on
this primary he weighed in saying this
will be very interesting and i can't
imagine that brian kemp who has hurt
election integrity in georgia so badly
can do well at the ballot blocks unless
the election is rigged of course he cost
his two senate seats and a presidential
victory in the great state of georgia
that's the former president clearly
weighing in on this republican race
well brett as i've said before look i
can't control what other people are
saying or doing i'm worried about what
people in georgia think i'm running to
be their governor not anybody else that
lives around the country or you know
anybody that's not concerned about this
race you look at my record on election
integrity even when i was secretary of
state when we didn't have any of these
issues going on i sued the obama justice
department to make sure we had a
citizenship check i defended our photo
id requirement in the court of law and
won against the obama justice department
and we're going to win against the biden
justice department who's suing over our
elections integrity act every single
republican in the georgia general
assembly voted for the elections
integrity act and they ran on their
record on november 3rd and had a great
night in the state of georgia even when
people like my opponent lost to a
political novice so do you think that
this primary the fact that it's
happening hurts republicans overall in
the ultimate goal to win back the
governor's
race
against davey stacey abrams well we saw
in virginia when everyone's united it
could be very powerful pushing back
against really the federal overreach of
the bide administration the disaster
that we've seen at the border you know
georgia's had national guard troops down
there supporting the border patrol
mission we saw the disastrous pull out
in afghanistan we've seen that the
policies of the biden administration and
the leftists in d.c have caused 30-year
inflation supply chain issues and other
things and it's been the republican
governors including myself that have
been providing solutions
for those issues and when we talk about
that we can win but when we get
distracted and fight one another you
know obviously that's not helpful we're
going to win the primary and then we're
going to beat stacey abrams in november
just like glenn younkin did atlanta
braves won the world series after the
all-star game was pulled out of georgia
george bulldogs are in the ncaa finals
even though they had a bump against the
road and up against the road in alabama
against alabama
it seems like things are going right in
georgia but it seems like this could be
a nasty fight governor
well listen republican primary politics
is tough you know i've been through that
before i'm not scared of that fight
that's the decision that someone else
has made
to create that fight i can't control
that i'm going to continue to talk to
georgians about what i think they care
about a great economy having our schools
open having secure accessible fair
elections i mean there's no doubt about
it i was frustrated like everybody else
i worked extremely hard for president
trump and our two u.s senators but also
for our whole ticket up and down the
ballot and we saw mechanical things that
we needed to fix in georgia and we did
and every single republican voted for it
but we've also been doing great things
with rural broadband to strengthen rural
georgia we've had great economic
development announcements here we're
doing great stuff with transportation
and logistics i mean you look at our
port in the state of georgia our two
ports versus you know la long beach and
other ports around the country we're
thriving we're moving goods we're making
sure that santa claus is going to be
present at christmas or as has delivered
at christmas and we have a lot of things
to be optimistic about in our state and
that is a message i'm going to be
running on not trying to blame somebody
else you know for my problems or tough
times that i've been through governor
brian kemp of georgia we appreciate your
time we'll follow this race
thanks brett hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else